hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video auf
dieses video freue mich ganz besonders
und zwar schwimmen das spiel reis auf
ukulele das wird von irgendwem von euch
gemacht tatsächlich ich habe hier über
gewinnt einer von euch spiele entwickeln
kann macht doch einfach mal schick mit
den link und das haben wir jetzt hier
wir haben ihr verschiedene
auswahlmöglichkeiten und zwar
einstellungen nun haben wir hintergrund
oder für musik video anschauen wir
starten jetzt einfach mal das spiel und
zwar bewege sich mit den tasten
ich kann hier sogar blaue springe mit
der leertaste okay ich kann also mit
kuli sogar springen und alter das geht
echt klar eigentlich das spiel ist auf
jeden fall jetzt geld was geht es ist
einfach unseren eis der spieler hat mich
so ein bisschen diesem geometrie fake
den ich mal gemacht haben das bringe ich
euch mal hier klickt da mal drauf da
habe ich so ein jailbreak gespielt da
könnt ihr aber die beiden spieler
miteinander vergleichen jedenfalls muss
ich wohl hier das geld einsammeln als da
sonst weil ihr um riesige gegner in dem
du auf sie drauf springt alles klar dann
lol was gehe ich finde es ein bisschen
crazy auch wenn ich nur ganz leicht auf
die leertaste drücke das ukulele dann so
richtig gas gibt aber sie ging runter
und das finde ich diesen check von jetzt
geholt habe gehe ich immer am besten
direkt wieder hoch jetzt tut mir
luca paolini stelle mal wieder davon
das ist ja super toll dass es ein spiel
über dich ist aber jetzt der hier wieder
gern springe ich kann einfach nur hoch
springen es ist unmöglich dieses geld
hier mitzunehmen man kann es nicht mit
nämlich ich spring von hier ich will das
geld mitnehmen ich kann nur darüber
springen wenn ich dann so
es geht nicht ins navi tello schießt
mich mit flaschen ab andere youtuber wie
pipi machen und heftiges spiele nicht so
gut dass man hier vitello kurz töten und
jetzt hier drüber und die skate vitello
wusste eigentlich weg ins bad place
vitello einfach mal hier
wir liegen über übrigens ganz viele
bücher einfach weil ich derzeit in
arbeit schreibt wird das ist auch dass
ich quasi einfach hier mit der maus
runter gehe kommt kommt comcom töten
noch den anderen italo ist dass ich mit
der maus mich quasi so ein bisschen
gucken kann das habe ich vorhin von
vergessen dass ich das ja machen kann
aber jetzt tut mir erstmal ganz kurz
hier luca altern ich hätte echt nicht
gedacht dass das spiel so nice wird wenn
ich euch einfach sagen wir sollten spiel
machen ich hoffe ihr seid alle vom
gehirn er so habe tatsächlich gerade
keine gute idee während ich hier
allerdings mal ganz kurz die karten
aufsammeln muss ich eine kleinigkeit
sagen und zwar meine snap chat story
wohl mich übrigens enden können ich
heiße der laser lukas pesek als nett
seht ihr neben so sachen wie
beispielsweise dem hier hat man nicht
kochen lade ich dann halt auch so sachen
hoch wie wenn ich feiern binden
und da sind wir sehr häufig im bootshaus
feiern das ist ein recht geiler klub ich
werde ich beispielsweise am 20 februar
auch abends mein geburtstag feiern und
so ein paar andere sachen aber das ist
erst mal komplett egal und ich feiere
den klub halt übels und ich bekomme
dafür jetzt nicht 40 millionen euro oder
1000 euro da whatever wie viel geld aber
ich habe euch einfach link in der
beschreibung gepackt wo ihr frühes
bootshaus worten könnte beim besten dj
bis beste klub der welt es ist kostenlos
ihr müsst euch da quasi nur mit google+
und ökologie spring spring gut wir
müssen euch da quasi nur mit google+
oder facebook kurz einloggen und die
post noch nichts auf eurer seite oder
irgendeinen krams sondern ihr könnt ja
quasi nur abstimmen bootshaus blabla ich
will mich auf jeden fall sehr freuen
weil der klub neiße ist die leute die da
sind sind als ihr seid nice und ich
denke wenn ich das mal findet das auch
ein alter ich bin luca ich fans auf
jeden fall sehr cool und würde mich sehr
freuen was ist denn dieses rote geld ist
das einfach mehr oder ich hab gerade
zehn geld bekommen damit unterstützen
wir quasi ein kuli
ich habe euch in linken mit dem
beschreibung gepackt wenn ihr spricht
auch nein ukulele
ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr da
abstimmt und es wäre mir sehr viel
freude währt wenn ach so meine damen und
herren
ja noch ein zweiter
du musst jeden schreibt mir mal bitte
ganz viele kommentare wie wir dieses mal
die nennen sollen bereits ab juli wenn
das spiel wirklich so lange ist werde
ich davon auf jeden fall mehrere paar zu
planen und dann brauchen wir nahmen für
die wir haben ja noch die zähne ich frag
mich nur noch um vorkommt nein nein
comcom töte ihn mein gott dieses spiel
ist schwierig alle da man glaubt es
nicht aber dieser vitello vor allem der
kanal gut schießen und wir haben den
nächsten checkpoint und das ist doch
nicht war kuli gehassten verdammtes ein
spiel kommen du kannst wenn du links
liegt rückstands und wenn wir hier
klasse trotzdem würden wir beiden sagen
wenn euch das video gefallen hat würden
wir uns selber eine bewertung freund es
geht ja anscheinend sogar noch weiter
wenn ich jetzt theoretisch auf menü
drücke und spiel starten er damit ich
zumindest schon mal beim letzten
checkpoint deswegen will ich sagen weil
lieben freunde wenn ich das video
gefallen hat und ihr noch einen zweiten
preis oft coletti haben wollt dann lasst
eine bewertung da steckt auf jeden fall
mal die beschreibung ab und baute
vielleicht fürs bootshaus er schon mal
wat findet ihr es dann wahrscheinlich
inhalts und wenn nicht dann worte
trotzdem und dann sehen wir uns in einem
nächsten parteikollege oder im nächsten
video wieder